>> Greg: ONE SHOULDN'T TAKE
CRAZY STUFF SERIOUSLY.
THERE'S NOTHING NORMAL ABOUT
CRAZY STUFF.
YOU DON'T WANT TO PRETEND THERE
IS.
PROBLEM IS, THIS IS THE GOLDEN
AGE OF CRAZY.
YEAH, THIS IN CALIFORNIA, THIS
IN LONDON, AND NOW IN BOSTON,
STATE DEMOCRATIC REP DAN HUNT
INTRODUCES A BILL THAT MAKES
USING THE WORD LET'S SAY USED TO
DESCRIBE A PREGNANT DOG
PUNISHABLE WITH SIX MONTHS OF
JAIL TIME.
BEFORE YOU DISMISS THIS AS
TIPPO, LET'S NOT FORGET IT MADE
IT THIS FAR FROM A CITIZEN TO A
GOVERNMENTAL BODY IN A LARGE
STATE.
CRAZY IS LIKE MOLD.
THE LONGER YOU LOOK AWAY, THE
BIGGER IT GETS.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
PRETEND CRAZY IS NEVER GOING TO
GET OUT OF ITS CRAZY LITTLE BOX.
CRAZY IS OUT OF THE BOX, WHICH
WAS THE COLLEGE CAMPUS.
AND THEN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE AND NOW IT'S SPREAD
TO MEDIA, TO H.R., TO
GOVERNMENT.
WHEN SANE PEOPLE GO FOR SHELTER,
THE CRAZY COMES OUT.
WHEN SOCIALISTS RUN FOR
PRESIDENT, WORDS GET BANNED,
SECRET CABALS UNDERMINE A DULY
ELECTED GOVERNMENT EGGED ON BY
THE MEDIA AND THEY CALL YOU
CRAZY?
REAL CRAZY IS ON THE MARCH.
CRAZY WANTS TO TURN MASS TO
JIBBERISH, THROWS FLUID ON
POLITICIANS, MOB PEOPLE AT THEIR
HOUSES, SPITS AND PUNCHES THOSE
FOR WEARING HATS, KEEPS THE SICK
AND DRUG ADDICTED ON THE
STREETS, BRANDS BIOLOGY A PHONY
CONSTRUCT AND NOW THEY WANT TO
MAKE INSULTS ILLEGAL?
WITH THEM RUNNING THE ASYLUM,
WHO CAN SAY THEY'RE WRONG?
JESSE, THIS CRIME TO SAY THE B
WORD -- I'M DOING THAT FOR THE
PRODUCERS.
I WOULD HAVE SAID IT.
YOU'RE WELCOME, MEGAN.
THIS CRIME ONLY NEEDS TO BE
VERIFIED BY THE PERSON BEING
CALLED A B WORD AND A WITNESS.
SO DANA AND I CAN SET THIS UP.
YOU CAN SAY JESSE CALLED YOU A B
AND I GET TO SIT THERE.
NOT REALLY.
YOU CAN --
>> Jesse: IF YOU WANT TO SWITCH
SEATS.
>> Greg: NO, YOU WOULD DO TO
JAIL -- WE SHOULD DO THAT
TOMORROW.
YOU'D GO TO JAIL AND PAY A FINE.
>> Jesse: THAT'S TRUE.
A BIG FINE.
WHEN THE PILGRIMS LANDED AND
THEY HAD NO FOOD, THEY SAID SON
OF A -- WE NEED SOMETHING TO
ELSE.
AND I THINK BAD WORDS WERE USED.
JOHN HANCOCK, IS THAT A PROBLEM?
HOW ABOUT THIS?
THE PATRIOTS.
THEY'RE PLAYING THE JETS.
TOM BRADY IS TALKING TRASH AT
THE DEFENSE MAKING THE JETS
DEFENSE IS.
THAT A PROBLEM IF THAT GETS
PICKED UP ON THE MIC?
ARE THEY GOING TO FINE TOM?
RIDICULOUS.
>> Greg: A SOUND ARGUMENT.
>> Jesse: I REST MY CASE.
>> Greg: JUAN, TWO STUDENTS WERE
ARRESTED AT UCONN FOR I THINK
THEY SAID THE N WORD.
WE HAVE THE TAPE.
BUT IT'S -- SHOW THE TAPE.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO HEAR
ANYTHING ANYWAY.
>> [BLEEP], [BLEEP], [BLEEP].
>> Greg: THAT'S GOOD.
THEY GOT ARRESTED.
YOU HAVE TO AGREE I DON'T THINK
THE FIRST AMENDMENT HAS AN
EXEMPTION FOR RACIST SPEECH.
>> Juan: NO, I'M A BIG PROPONENT
OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
WHEN YOU YOU HAVE HATE SPEECH
LIKE BURNING A CROSS --
>> Greg: IT'S AN ACT.
>> Juan: BUT IT'S HATE SPEECH.
BUT WHAT YOU SAID WITH TOM BRADY
DEMEANING THE DEFENSE, THAT IS
NOT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT, THIS IS
ABOUT USING THE LANGUAGE TO
INTIMIDATE AND INSULT.
THAT'S WHY THE WOMAN WENT TO HER
POLITICIAN AND --
>> Greg: THIS IS ILLEGAL.
WHAT A WEAK PERSON.
>> Juan: BUT TO MY MIND, YOU DO
HAVE WORDS THAT ARE FIGHTING
WORDS THAT CAN CAUSE PUBLIC
HARM.
YOU CAN'T SCREAM FIRE IN A
CROWD --
>> Greg: THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS
IS.
BY THE WAY, HOW MANY PEOPLE
SHOUT FIRE IN A CROWDED THEATER?
IT SHOULD BE ILLEGAL.
>> Juan: THIS HAPPENED WITH
WESTBORO BAPTIST CHURCH.
THEY WERE ALLOWS TO HOLD A
PROTEST AT THE MILITARY BECAUSE
THEY OPPOSE THE ACCEPTANCE OF
GAY PEOPLE.
AT SOME POINT, THE COURTS DID
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU CAN'T INTERFERE.
YOU HAVE TO STOP.
YOU'RE DEMEANING PEOPLE IN THE
MIDST OF EXPRESSING THEIR GRIEF.
>> Greg: WHAT IS INTERESTING
ABOUT WESTBORO, AT LEAST THEY
SET A STANDARD.
THAT'S LIKE THAT IS SO AWFUL.
>> Dana: OBVIOUS.
>> Greg: YES.
>> Dana: WHAT IS IRONIC, YOU
HAVE A STATE LIKE MASSACHUSETTS
WHERE -- IT'S BIPARTISAN BUT
MOSTLY COMING FROM THE LEFT,
THAT YOU SHOULD REDUCE JAIL
TIME.
NOW THEY WANT TO INCREASE JAIL
TIME FOR THIS PERSON.
ALSO, YOU LISTED THE PLACES
WHERE THIS ORIGINATED AND
AFFECTED ALL OF OUR PLACES BUT
YOU FORGOT THE UNITED KINGDOM.
THIS HAPPENS IN BRITAIN.
YOU CAN BE ARRESTED BECAUSE --
JESSE OVERHEARD US TALKING AND
NOW -- THEN WE'RE MARCHED OFF OF
FOX NEWS.
>> Greg: OR --
>> Dana: AND THEIR LIST IS NOT
JUST THE B WORD.
IT'S ANYTHING.
>> Greg: YOU MIX GENDER, YOU'RE
A CANDIDATE, TOO.
DR. NICOLE, SWEARING IS
THERAPEUTIC.
>> IT IS CATHARTIC.
THERE'S SMALL STUDIES THAT SHOW
THAT IT RELEASES ENDORPHINS AND
STRESS RELIEF.
THIS IS ENCROACHING ON THE FIRST
AMENDMENT.
IT'S A BROAD OVERSTRETCH FOR
DISORDERLY CONDUCT.
THEY NEED TO STAY AWAY FROM
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
>> Jesse: REMEMBER WHEN DANA
CURSED ON THE SHOW?
>> Dana: TRUTH IS A DEFENSE.
>> I DON'T TRUST PEOPLE THAT
CURSE --
>> Dana: WHEN A GUY TAKES AN
ALLIGATOR AND RUNS AROUND A
STORE -- HE SHOULD BE CALLED